HAOHSIANG LIAO: My
name is Haohsiang Liao.
I'm the senior lecturer
directing the Chinese Language
Program here at MIT.
And since I've been here, I've
been in charge of Chinese 101
to Chinese 104 and
that's basically
the beginning level to the
intermediate level of Chinese.
So my interest in
teaching languages
started when I was a
grad student in Taiwan.
That was this time
that Taiwan started
to establish its first grad
school of teaching Chinese
as a second language,
which was about 1994.
So I was a grad
student there and that
was the time I started
to develop my interest
in teaching foreigners Chinese.
So I was there for
three years and they
got me an opportunity to do an
internship at Williams College.
So I was at Williams for
one year and at Williams,
that was the eye-opening
experience for me
and that was really the moment
I decided to devote myself
into this profession.